that you can react to I'm going to ask
I'm going to ask our director to do
something for us since we're on the
story of tim geithner come back to me if
you can it's interesting but one of the
plans that he's explaining to Senator
Shelby is a plan to take all the bad
debt in the United States and put it in
one bank the federal government would
actually create a bank filled with
nothing but bad debt it's actually being
called the bad bank I want to get
reaction on this from Professor Myron
but before we do that we've asked Salman
Khan who's also an economist and who
also has one of the most curious
websites that you'll ever find Salman
Khan calm on the Internet where he draws
these things so that we can all
understand because the average person
can't understand these things watch what
he's done dan this is not the next
soundbite that we were expecting I want
you to jump when I had thanks here it is
Salman Khan on this bad bank idea
presented today like you've never seen
it i've drawn here a simple balance
sheet for a bank the left-hand side is
the assets assets this is the
liabilities is what they owe to other
people liabilities and here's the equity
or the stock what the government wants
to do is take these assets right here
off the hands of the banks and this is
apparently because these banks can't
sell these assets or at least they can't
sell these assets for what these banks
need to sell the mat in order to be able
to meet their liabilities and in order
to continue lending again so the idea
behind the bad bank plan and the details
are still coming out so this is my best
guess that they want to create a new
bank here where some of the money is
going to come from the government so
let's say half of it comes from the
government this is from the government
this is the cash that the government
puts in initially and then the other
half comes from the private sector I
don't know if it's half maybe it's a lot
more comes from the government may be a
lot more comes from the private sector
private sector and then using all of
this cash that comes from both the
government and the private sector they
would go and buy these assets for more
than the banks can sell them for right
now if these assets really are worth
what they pay then this bad bank
call this a bad bank bad bank might do
okay on the other hand if the current
market that's only paying a lot less for
this asset let's say the current markets
only paying less for this asset and
we're overpaying by a certain amount
that over payment amount relative to the
real value of the asset is essentially a
subsidy of the stock and the bondholders
of the current company that's why we
call a participatory journalism we think
if there's somebody on the internet it
was real good at explaining things we're
going to tap them and tap their
resources like we did right there let's
take it now to a Harvard professor
jeffrey miron did you see that I get a
good education but here's the here's the
question I really have for you will it
work I don't think that